breaking news in the Middle East the US
has now launched air strikes on Iranian
backed militias all in response to the
deadly drone attack that killed three
soldiers at a US military base in Jordan
last weekend today strikes targeted
dozens of sites used by the militias in
both Syria and Iraq after the Biden
Administration warned there would be
retaliation Reggie Chini joins us now
from Washington Reggie what do we know
so far I need to since Sunday when
President Joe Biden said quote we shall
respond we've known something was in the
works although details were a bit
nebulous beyond the talking point that
these Iranian proxies deemed responsible
for this drone attack last Sunday needed
to be held accountable but it's a
difficult Balancing Act well the US has
been clear it doesn't want a broader war
with Iran these groups are connected
militarily and financially with tyan so
what do we know well 85 targets were
struck by numerous aircraft including
the longrange B1 bomber with us Central
Command saying these were command and
control centers intelligence centers and
weapon supply lines and we're hearing
from Syrian State television that the
strikes have been deadly it is
noteworthy that this response came just
hours after Biden attended the dignified
transfer of the three service members
killed in Sunday's attack now President
Biden has been under pressure from some
Republicans who argued he wasn't moving
fast enough but this is a moment that
carries potential political consequences
this is an election year and the
president has been steadfast in his
position of not having the US drawn into
a broader Middle East war and while the
White House confirms tonight that
strikes will continue at times and
places of its choosing they say it's not
expected to be within Iran yet e Reggie
Chini in Washington thanks Reggie